the only people who now get married are
people who are relatively wealthy you
know the fact that we've disrupted the
structure of marriage as an institution
since about 1965 say what that's meant
what that has meant is that it's its
benefits are now only available to
people who are privileged so you can
look up the stats yourself but if you're
middle class and above the divorce rates
haven't moved much since the early 70s
if you're working class and below it's a
complete catastrophe and what that's
meant is that most men many children who
are in rougher socio-economic straights
are being raised by a single person who
is absolutely and 100-percent
overwhelmed by their multiple
commitments right full-time
responsibility for children and
generally in employment in an
extraordinarily dismal low-paying
unstable and exploitative job so to me
if you if you're like you guys are
you're all gonna be middle class or
above and all likelihood it's like it's
fine for you it's not gonna make a
bloody bit of difference all things
considered but for people who are poor
it's just being a catastrophe so ok so
yes
oh well there's all sorts of reasons I
mean first of all it's become socially
acceptable right divorce wasn't socially
acceptable and you can say well that's
that was pretty hard on people who
wanted to get divorced it's like yeah
obviously any rule is hard on people
that break it but that doesn't mean that
there shouldn't be rules you know
now what rules there should be that's a
whole different issue out of wedlock
childbirth has become a norm it was
absolutely rare in the nineteen nineteen
sixties vanishingly rare and that's
become it's it's acceptable even though
all the evidence suggests like if you
actually look at the evidence it's
absolutely clear that kids who have two
parents do better than kids who have one
now you know people when you tell people
that they'll tell you an anecdote about
someone they knew maybe their own parent
who did a wonderful job of raising them
as a single person it's like the
anecdotes are irrelevant but what's
relevant is the bulk of the evidence of
course there are situations where people
are better apart than together and of
course there are situations where one
person can do a better job than two
people who are at each other's throats
but it's it's aggregate it's aggregating
examples that you use when you're doing
a scientific survey and the results of
those surveys are crystal clear you know
the other thing that's going to happen
it's going to happen very soon is that
there is going to be a very very very
very large number of elderly people who
are alone and being elderly and alone
like no family that is not something you
want to look forward to especially when
you start thinking that you're gonna be
elderly for like forty years so you know
because say say it starts around 65 I
don't know how long you guys are gonna
live but it's probably 95 is not an
unreasonable estimate and it might be
longer than that so because you know
we're adding about three months to the
total lifespan every year right that's
the rate of technological improvement in
relationship to overall mortality so you
know and that the degree to which we're
adding that extra lifespan is increasing
each year you know and it may hit get to
the point where we're increase
lifespan a year every year now I doubt
it because it'll probably East it'll
probably be an asset a sim tote but it
has been increasing for a very long
period of time so you know it's one
thing to think about the maximization of
day-to-day freedom when you're between
say 15 and and 4045 after that that's a
whole different story and but modern
people never think about the last half
of their life you know so why I don't
know but maybe they're afraid to or
something